welcome to exploring computing
today's video is linking web pages
part two formatting links so in the last
video we took a look at linking
different web pages and what our options
are when using links
in this video we're going to take a look
at how you can format your links and
along the way we'll learn about pseudo
classes which can be used for quite a
number of other formatting purposes in
addition to links
so you've all probably seen a link that
looks like this this is the standard
appearance of a link
it's underlined and it's blue so
let's uh first take care of that
underline so if you want to play around
with the underline that's actually
controlled by the text decoration style
property
and you can get rid of it by setting
text decoration to none so here i've got
a rule that says hey all anchors
and remember you know these are being
created by ahrefs so
that's an anchor tag all anchors turn
the text decoration off
you should be cautious about this though
because
people see that underline and they think
it's a link
um also as a side note a related note
be cautious about underlining things
that aren't links because people are
used to things being underlined as being
linked so they're going to try and click
on
like why is this thing not working this
website's busted
all right so if you decide you don't
like that underline for your links
now you've got an issue where you've got
a bunch of
things that you know are links on your
web page but like
how does the user know that they're
linked so here i've got a bunch of
colored
uh words and are these links
are they not links which of these are
links it's really hard to say and so
um 160 students we'll talk about this
later in the quarter uh we've got a
lecture on
human computer interaction and there's
what's
sometimes referred to as an affordance
which is a way of saying
your user interface should make it clear
to the user that there's
some sort of interaction that can occur
and ideally it should give you a sense
of what interaction can occur
uh and so a common example of this is um
you know we've all been we've we've had
those
glass doors and you know if there's a
push bar on there it's very clear that
you're supposed to push it
and if there's a handle you know that's
easy to grab
that's generally a sign that you should
pull it so those are called affordances
they're
something that the human brain looks at
it says oh i see how i'm supposed to
interact with this
and by removing the underlines here
you've basically removed the affordance
that's telling people
that oh that's a link i should go ahead
and click on it
so be cautious all right um you can also
you know if you want to guess them up
you can go the other direction be like
hey i don't want just an underline
i want to overline an underline so it
turns out you can do this by
just setting text decoration and putting
both overline and
underline uh with a space between the
two and that'll create this effect
you're seeing here
okay another thing that happens with
links is the links are different colors
right so
you know we've seen the standard links
um
they're pretty boring so you know if you
don't want to use the standard likes i
think that totally makes sense but
we have seen these all before so i'm
going to start off with these for now
we've got these standard links and uh
you know if you've played around with
the web for a while you probably realize
that that first
article that's a link to another web
page and the second one
is a link to another web page but i've
already visited that other web page
um it turns out that there's a there's a
third color
associated with links um
i i don't know how many people actually
realize this uh i i don't think i did
until i
started playing around with these you
know the back end learning how to
actually make the web pages but
there's a third color where you you
actually click on the link
while you are currently pressed down on
that link with like the mouse and a
i assume the same thing happens with
finger i haven't really noticed it with
a finger but
if you are actively pressing down before
you release the mouse
and presumably before you lift your
finger it actually changes to a third
color
so there's a standard color there's a
visited color and then there's a
color while actively clicking on the
link
um so
there's a problem with this and the
problem is how how are we going to do
this
how are we going to create these colors
so one thing you can imagine is
uh you know i can have
one class for links that i haven't
visited in a second class for
links that i have visited so dot link
hey the color's blue
dot visit it the color's purple but
the problem with this is okay here's the
html for that
i've got the two links and one of my
mark is class equals link and one of my
mark is class equals visited
but the fact that somebody has visited a
page
actually varies from one person to
another so unless i serve up
different versions of my html file to
different people depending on whether
they've visited links
this does not work i can't have class
equals visited
for some people if they have visited
that page before and
class not having visited for other
people
i can only serve a single version of the
html file
and so there's no way to distinguish
whether an individual person has visited
that
or not so this is seems to be kind of a
problem
i mean it would be really nice if i if i
could do this and so it actually turns
out
the solution basically does look like
this but it's a little bit different
because
the computer automatically adds this
sort of what it refers to as a pseudo
class so it acts
as if there's a class on these anchor
elements
either link or visit it depending on
whether the person has visited that web
page or not
but it's sort of added internally by the
web browser and so i serve up just
when i'm when my web server serving up
copies the html file to people it does
not have marked whether it's visited or
a regular link because it doesn't know
and then
when the person gets that file their web
browser sort of figures out it's like oh
i see that's a link
uh that link you've actually visited so
that's gonna fit in this pseudo class
visited i'm gonna pretend
it is as if there was a class equals
visited on it even though
it's not actually in the original html
source this one
you haven't visited so i'm just going to
assume that i'm going to act as if this
is class
equals link instead of the class equals
visited it
even though again none of those are
actually present it's as if there was a
class on it
but the class is not actually on the
elements it's something that
the web browser is dynamically working
out on its own
and we're going to distinguish between
real classes and pseudo classes because
the pseudo classes are going to have
colons in front of them instead of dots
in our style sheets so here i've got
three pseudo classes call on link
call and visit it and call inactive so
colon link
that's going to be the pseudo class
when i have a link on my web page
and the user has not visited that link
before
call and visit it that's going to be the
pseudo class associated with
an a tag if there's a link on there and
the users actually visited it and then
colon active
that's going to be the pseudo class
associated with an a tag when somebody's
actually
actively clicking on it now when you
actually write these out for your style
sheet you actually want to put the a
in front of us so a colon link a colon
visited a con active so we're combining
the fact that
hey i want this to apply to anchor tags
and i
don't want to just just apply to any
anchor tag i want this to apply to
anchor tags
where we've got that active pseudo class
colon visited or where we've got that
active pseudo class colon active um
why do we need to put the acorn there it
turns out there's a bunch of pseudo
classes and some of these actually work
on different elements so
just using the example we've got here
acorn active
that's the color when somebody clicks on
a link
there's also a button colon active where
somebody clicks on a button and you want
the button to change color
if we were to just say colon active it
would not be clear to the web browser
whether this applies to link colors
or to button colors or to both and i
think it would actually just use it for
both but
that may not be what you want so
definitely put the a columns in front
and so here's the example again i've
changed the colors because who wants to
use the standard blue and purple
um so we can see so i've got my links
and you could say
i i'm saying if i've got a link
normal link that should appear red
visited link that should appear
green and active link that should appear
in blue
there are a bunch of other pseudo
classes there's actually quite a few
here's
some of the fancier handier ones it says
there's a first child on the last child
so let's say you have a list of items
and you want to do something different
with the first time in the list like
maybe you want
that first item in the list to have a
bit of extra margin
uh in front of it or you know maybe the
last child you want to uh put it put a
line underneath the last item
and so these are going to
you're going to be able to use these on
your elements uh so you're going to be
able to use these in your style sheets
to select particular elements and
there's the nth
child um so ant child three that says
hey here's a style rule but i only want
it to
apply to the third element of this
list of elements or um let's say you're
trying to do zebra striping on a table
that's where you've got
some sort of table and every other line
is a
different color so you've got like a
bunch of dark gray lines and a bunch of
light gray lines
it looks a little bit nicer it's a
little bit easier for people to tell
what's going on with the table
you can do that using the nth child odd
and add to child even and so that would
be a rule where you say
hey every odd element in this table i
want to use this particular style
and every even element on this table i'm
going to use this other style
so those are pseudo classes so that's it
for our discussion on links
we've learned quite a bit more about
links from the html side
and we also learned a bit about styling
them
and this idea of pseudo classes can come
in handy in a bunch of other places as
well
all right i'll talk to you soon
you